Ми самі тут, перші сусіди на допомогу,
бо більше тут немає нікого вище нас.
Саме звідси ідуть наші дані лавинної
небезпеки в українських Карпатах.
Ми — спеціалізована сніголавинно
метеорологічна станція,
яка займається прогнозом лавин.
Вісімдесят шість.
Вісімдесят.
Дев'яносто вісім.
Ми надаємо всі метеорологічні дані для
погоди і займаємось суто лавинами.
Є лавини хуртовинного снігу,
свіжовипалого снігу і мокрого снігу.
Звичайно, взимку, коли температура
-15–20°, іде перенос снігу.
Звісно, це будуть лавини
хуртовинного снігу.
Якщо навесні є відлига, значить,
будуть лавини мокрого снігу.
І тому ми тут —
щоб спостерігати за тим явищем.
Наразі ми
на метеомайданчику,
з якого наші працівники знімають покази,
на якому є наші пристрої.
Оце перед нами — пристрій М–63, який
визначає швидкість і напрямок вітру.
Оце перед нами — психрометрична
будка, в якій є чотири термометри:
мінімальний, максимальний, терміновий.
Але, крім цього, у нас є в будці
електронний вимірювач температури.
Він електронно показує
у приміщенні станції
на комп'ютері на сайті температуру
повітря змочену, суху тощо.
Ця професія була ще за Польщі.
Тут ще працювали раніше
поляки-метеорологи, ботаніки були.
А потім, в 1950-х роках, уже наша
станція почала працювати.
Оскільки вона спочатку була
на крилі біостаціонару,
там було виділено одну-дві кімнатки
для метеорологів,
а згодом на тому місці,
де цей вагончик стоїть, збудували станцію.
Та станція існувала до 1986-го року.
В 1986-му році була збудована оця станція.
Лавини — це зсув снігу.
Для того щоб знати, коли зійде лавина,
у нас є п'ять ступенів лавинної небезпеки.
— Вася, ти лопату взяв?
— Так.
Ми виходимо, копаємо такі шурфи, ями,
є у нас спеціальні пристої.
Ми робимо пенетрацію снігу
на твердість, беремо щільність,
визначаємо температуру снігу між шарами,
бо утворюються шари:
льодова кірка, радіаційна кірка,
снігова кірка тощо.
Для цього ми сідаємо, визначаємо це все,
після чого заносимо це в комп'ютер.
Там є програма, яка вибиває нам
всю систему снігового накопичення.
Для чого ця станція й поставлена —
щоб попередити людей,
щоб вони не лізли,
бо можуть спровокувати лавину.
Може бути не лавинонебезпечно, але люди
самі можуть підрізати лавину, і вона зійде.
Коли передається лавинна небезпека
третього ступеня, в гори бажано не ходити
і не лізти під схил, де більше 35°,
тому що це може спровокувати лавину.
Дев'яносто шість.
Мій внук дивився, що я тут
пропрацював усе своє життя,
і я йому запропонував піти до нас.
Зараз він вже два роки працює тут.
Сто сорок один.
Вася, де ти є? Ти вже що, на язику?
Зараз перший півкілометр закінчується.
Що-що?
Де ти зараз є? Бо зараз 500 метрів, перший
кілометр з одного боку закінчується.
Ти щось дуже швидко пройшов.
Я хотів їхати за кордон
або підписувати контракт,
бо відслужив строкову службу
і хотів підписати контракт.
Але я щось передумав,
повернувся на дембель додому,
і мені Михайло Васильович
запропонував роботу.
Коли ходиш, лавини робиш, як лавина
зійшла, наприклад, то ти собі думаєш:
«Чи вона зійде чи не зійде?»
Сто тридцять шість.
Бо коли третій, п'ятий, шостий шурф
копаєш, там ще більша небезпека,
тому що ти копаєш шурф
саме там, де лавина має сходити.
Там треба ще знати,
як підійти до нього правильно,
щоб просто не стати не там, де треба, аби
ти не з'їхав, не поїхав разом з лавиною.
Це екстремальна, по суті, робота.
Скільки?
118, 119, 120, 121...124.
124.
Насамперед потрібно підібрати кадри,
які зможуть прижитися до гір.
Коли вітер — 20–25 м/с
і носить хмари над станцією,
звісно, це не кожна людина може перенести.
А тому підбираються такі люди,
які люблять гори,
сильні духом і з хорошою
фізичною витримкою.
На станції постійно працює три зміни.
У кожній зміні взимку
є три людини, влітку — дві,
тому що завжди одна у відпустці
і тільки таким методом ми можемо
працювати й утримувати людей на роботі.
Вони працюють тиждень,
а потім два — вони вдома.
Далі у нас є для
вимірювання снігу три рейки.
Перша є у тому керунку,
друга — в цьому, і третя — в цьому.
От зараз, бачите, 57–58 см снігу
на цій рейці, на тій — трошки більше.
Отой столик у нас —
щоб вимірювати рівень радіації.
Наші техніки зранку
о дев'ятій годині виходять на майданчик,
ставлять там пристрій ДРГ
і вимірюють радіацію,
так би мовити, радіоактивність, яка
може прийти до нас з будь-якого керунку,
і тому ми вимірюємо її ранком та передаємо
у вигляді телеграм РБХ,
які відправляються в Київ.
Вперше я сюди
потрапив в 1972-му році.
І потрапив випадково.
Я тоді вчився у технікумі,
але працював у нашому Ворохтянському
лісокомбінаті на тракторі.
І мене запросив той начальник.
Я привозив сюди дрова трактором.
Був такий Микола Миколайович Гуцуляк, який
сказав: «Ти би не хотів у нас працювати?».
Я відповів: «Що я тут буду робити,
як у мене немає освіти?».
А він мені каже: «Якщо маєш бажання, мені
треба людина, яка б тут працювала.
Ми тебе будемо вчити. Ти згідний?».
Я кажу: «Згідний».
Так сталося, як сталося. І я прийшов
сюди і відтоді почав працювати.
Працював я довго спостережником,
потім роки старшим техніком,
а вже зараз я працюю
начальником цієї станції.
Значить, шановні, трошки заждіть,
бо ми тільки поставили чайник.
А вам цукру давати, не давати?
Цукру?
По дві ложечки? Добре.
Ми вам дамо у пакетиках.
Так, добре. Ідемо.
Останні роки більшість туристів — ну це
любителі, бо вони раніше ходили у Крим.
Тепер через те що Крим закритий,
у нас є в Ворохті туркомплекс «Ворохта» —
вони ідуть на екскурсію,
ну і ми їх, звісно, вітаємо з тим,
що вони приходять до нас,
тому що вони стежку нам пробивають.
Бо, знаєте, коли їх прийде 20 осіб і
назад 20, то можна подякувати таким людям,
бо є стежечка і нам уже не треба
йти по пояс у снігу.
Але буває таке, що хтось із непланових
туристів вийшов у гори, пізно прийшов.
Приходять до нас вдруге, ми мусимо їх
прийняти і дати прихисток, бо то є люди.
Для вимірювання
сонячного сяйва у нас є геліограф.
Працює він так: закладається тут стрічечка,
сонечко проходить коло і пропалює її.
Після обіду в істинний полудень
стрічка знімається в перші
ми обертаємо на північ сам геліограф,
і відмітка сонячного сяйва
продовжується далі.
А так за свій час, поки я тут працював,
я зустрічався і з вовком, і з ведмедем,
бо роки такі —
колись рвав малину і ведмідь тут
буквально теж ласував собі малинками.
Я думав, що то такий самий клієнт, як я.
А підійшовши ближче, побачив, що це ведмідь.
Ну, я повернувся в один бік, він —
в інший. Ми мирно розійшлися.
Я чомусь полюбив ці гори.
Я сам живу в горах,
але коли вперше прийшов
сюди на роботу, вона мені сподобалась.
І фізично дуже добре почуваюся,
бо в мене вже такий вік, знаєте,
що можна сидіти вдома,
але я так почуваюся в цих горах людиною,
що без них, напевно, не зможу далі бути,
тому я закоханий в ці гори
і люблю цю роботу
і скільки Бог дасть здоров'я,
стільки буду працювати.
Взагалі, мене самі гори зачаровують.
Ота краса, коли вийти зараз
подивитися на сам хребет,
який прекрасний Чорногірський масив,
то, звичайно, кращого, напевне, немає ніде.
І я не дивуюсь тим людям, які
приїжджають зараз зі Сходу до нас
і дійсно говорять: «Ми не бачили земного раю.
Ми бачимо тут земний рай».
Тому для мене гори — моє життя і все.